[Music]
so thank you all for coming
I'm Chris I'm working as a freelance
data scientist for various clients in
industry I used to work in academia
during my PhD and explain at conferences
the deep details of algorithms this is
completely different so I'm happy to do
a talk like this data scientists love
diagrams and I'm no exception and also
data scientists love to describe what
they are in terms of a diagram and I
found this one which is quite correct I
would say as the perfect data scientists
here in the middle we need to combine
skills from different areas of course
programming statistics but also business
understanding and communication skills
and always keep them balanced so we
don't end up as head of IT or computer
science professor or hacker and the
internet is full of the data science
workflow as diagram of course there's
more than one workflow but I thought
this one is a is one that occurs
frequently in predictive modeling
projects for example you need to go
through the process of acquiring the
data ingesting the data and cleaning it
up thinking about storage and management
especially in big data scenarios
thinking about extracting the right
features the whole process is known as
data wrangling throughout that you often
use visual analysis and you need to work
interactively with the data then you go
to building your model of course you
need to evaluate your model performance
and in the end when you're done and have
a good model you need to tell a story
about it to your stakeholders and
present the results unfortunately Python
has you covered throughout all the
stages of this data science workflow and
we have to speak of an ecosystem of
tools I thought it said that's a great
analogy
we see also an ecosystem that's marine
life in Antarctica and the arrows show
you which species is consumed by which
species and there are some that are very
central and others that are very
specialized small ones big ones and I
was reminded of this picture when I drew
this dependency graph of some of the
Python modules that I'm going to discuss
I think that it looks somehow similar
and as life in a sea life in antarctica
depends on krill our life as data
scientists somehow depends on numpy
apparently the most central one so first
of all i'm going to talk about the tools
that are very important in data
wrangling and let's start with numpy
probably most of you are familiar with
this it's a fundamental package for
numeric computing in Python and it
provides maintaining an N dimensional
array object also powerful mechanisms to
apply functions efficiently to this
object and some math functions from
linear algebra generating random numbers
and so on and this numpy nd array is a
data structure that for example can
represent two-dimensional matrix in the
Python view and the trick here is to
layout the numeric data in memory so
that efficient high-performance
computing can happen with that a matrix
could also be implemented with the
Python this type however the list is as
you probably know first of all an array
of addresses to objects that could be
stored anywhere in memory so this is one
of the core tricks of high-performance
computing
lay out the data efficiently in memory
in consecutive blocks and of course I
can't explain all the aspects of numpy
if I had to summarize numpy and why it's
important in one slide I would say
understanding numpy helps you to lose
the loops in your code
if we like here generate a million
random numbers and take the logarithm of
these numbers we can do this elegantly
with Python this comprehension
however this is still a Python loop with
a certain overhead and formulating this
in Nampa allows us to push the loop down
into compiled code and get speed ups
usually of an order of magnitude or two
orders of magnitude so it pays off to
understand numpy to write efficient code
the next tool for data wrangling is
pandas and it's really the bread and
butter of the data scientists used
throughout the process
pandas provides you with a labelled
index array data structures for example
the kind of series or data frame
efficient operations like join or
grouping operations has extensive
support for working with time series of
course it cares about input and output
in from the usual formats and also gives
you some statistics capabilities and if
you're new to pandas and the best
introduction is a real example for me it
was real because it was given to me in a
job interview the task was hey here find
the correlation between the inhabitants
and a number of the museum's of the
department's of France and given were
two data falls apart Moss and list
museum ok you have 10 minutes pandas to
the rescue
pandas imports the data from the city
from CSV and we can look into the date
the resulting data frame and since we
only care about the population and the
name of the department we filter these
two columns and throw away the rest we
look at the other file that's an Excel
format
same thing here it's a list of all the
museums in France with certain
attributes among others the department
and which Museum is located now we only
care about the number of museums per
department so we apply the Kroop by
operator in pandas and we get back this
series of
mapping the department name to the
number of museums then we need to join
the two data items so they match we need
to do a bit of string processing on the
names of the departments also pandas
helps us here with the efficient apply
function we need to set the index
correctly so the following merge
operation works and if you do all this
correctly we get this data frame that's
very close to our desired solution and
then after we convert the data to
numeric format correctly we can call
this correlation function and get back
the answer and we can be done in ten
minutes if we have practiced our pandas
skills which pays off throughout the
process
now you've practiced your panda skills
and suddenly you're faced with big data
that doesn't fit into memory what now an
option you have here is tasks tasks is a
module that provides many things for
parallel computing but among other
things it provides the desk data frame
that's an object that combines many
pandas dataframes split along the index
and mimics the pandas API so you can
transfer your pandas skills to Big Data
scenarios and apply to distributed
computing for example so now to a block
of tools for visual exploration and
presentation of the data that's the
tools marked in green here from the
fundamental one which you probably know
is matplotlib so standard 2d plotting
library and simple plots can be created
rather easily and quickly in pandas in
math or lip but if you have some
experience with matplotlib
usually doesn't stay that concise so you
have a very fine grained control about
the the look of the figure and it can
get very verbose
as a practitioner it's very good debt
there are modules on top of matplotlib
like for example Seaborn Seaborn aims to
give us production-ready statistical
graphics for example graphics about
fitting and visualizing linear
regression models or matrix data or time
series and so on it works really nicely
together with pandas and on PI data
structures and it gives you improved as
they say improved styling of metal lip
graphics translators as it usually looks
cool out of the box what you can do with
Seabourn small example you may know the
this data said that's a frequent toy
dataset in statistics
it's about flowers and it shows you how
certain species of the iris flower can
be separated by measurement of the
sepals and petals and one thing that
Seabourn allows you for example with a
pear plot function is to plot
projections two-dimensional projections
of always two attributes against each
other so you can quickly explore the
data set and in this example for example
this discover that the species are
nicely separable in certain projections
of the data space but what if you want
more interactivity in your graphics
there you have the option of using
bouquet bouquet there's many of the same
things that map table does however it's
focuses on interactive graphics in
modern web browsers as a target platform
it's very useful if you want to build
interactive dashboards or data
applications and it's inspired by
JavaScript library the 3GS
so with bouquet you can do things in a
very similar way to matplotlib and
generate figures with very fine-grained
control to customize your figures but
you get interactivity for free sort of
so in any web browser you get for
example zoomable and scalable graphics
to inspect the data interactively and
there's a third entry for data
visualization there's a cool new library
called hollow views that I'm looking
forward to apply in practice their claim
is however use lets you focus on what
you are trying to explore and convey not
a process of plotting not the details of
plotting so what they say is annotate
your data with semantic metadata and
sort of let it plot itself and you can
use math or lip or bouquet as the back
end and also easily switch between these
two backends so this slide really needs
an example because it's very abstract
here we have a data set on certain
macroeconomic indicators of countries
over time and this block of code shows
you how you can annotate this data set
with hollow views and the next slide
will show how the plotted result looks
like what we want to do in our
exploration of this dataset is relate
dimensions like the unemployment or GDP
growth to dimensions like the year and
the name of the country so we sort of
wrap this pandas dataframe in a hollow
use table annotated with these this
metadata and then basically plotting the
data in this format is one line plotted
as a stacked bar chart and you can give
with this notation you can give the
plotting function certain
graphical options like the width and
height of the figure and so on so we see
that we nicely separate the optical
details from the thing we want to do and
of course since you will use bouquet as
a back-end this is a interactive figure
and it also gives us this hover tool to
inspect the data now we can proceed to
the modeling phase want to protect build
predictive models for example and the
starting most important starting points
from the pine ecosystem are scikit-learn
and stats models for this purpose so I
could learn is the first address for
machine learning in Python it provides
you of course a collection of machine
learning algorithms for example
classification for regression for
clustering for dimensionality reduction
and so on and I think equally
importantly it provides you building
blocks for the pre-processing of your
data and them for your model selection
workflows cyclones modular approach
gives you such constructs as estimators
transformers and pipelines which are
really useful when you want to build
machine learning workflows in a
methodical way transformer can do some
pre-processing step on your data you fit
the data with the transformer and later
it can transform the data frame in some
way for example inferring missing values
and so on an estimator is a tool that
gives you a prediction in the end also
you fit it to the data and apply it to
test set to get final predictions and
this is so modular that you can also
plug it together to into pipelines
for example a series of transformers can
be wrapped in a pipeline which is again
a transformer so you can build these
nested structures stats models is also a
library that's used in the model
building phase it gives you statistical
models tests and tools for the
exploration of the data and it is sort
of pythons answer to the our language it
contains things like regression models
tools for time series analysis and
statistical tests and so if both
scikit-learn
and sets models give you tools for
building predictive models what is their
what what is the difference on are they
not placed in the same ecological niche
so which one should you select for which
purpose that small since I could learn
do have many models in common for
example ordinary least-squares
regression or logistic regression
however there are key differences so I
could learn is focus strongly on machine
learning and gives you this modular
approach the fit transform predict
workflows we've seen quickly and in the
sense it's more you could call it more
pythonic stats models on the other hand
focus on on heavy statistical analysis
and modeling it's more it gives you more
hardcore statistics capabilities for
example more diagnostic model parameters
and it feels more are like
okay in predictive modeling we often
work with tabular data and I thought I
should also quickly have a section on
something completely different this is
also data analysis but it's slightly
different view this is network analysis
network analysis looks not a tabular
data of items and their attributes but
of items and their connections so this
is a toy example that's often used in
network analysis it turns out that
dolphins also form social networks of
friendships and in one's study the
researchers have modeled this social
network of dolphins with network
analysis modeled it as a graph and
applied different analysis algorithms
through them okay
lots of marine life by coincidence here
in my slides but it's and I think it's a
nice example for this network analysis
workflow and if you want to get started
with network analysis in Python then
most friendly tool to get started
probably Network X helps you with the
creation the manipulation and the study
of the structure of complex networks and
it provides of course a collection of
algorithms for network analysis for
example centrality measures the one on
PageRank is one of them certainly also
algorithms for constructing these graphs
and so on is written in pure Python so
very flexible any object can be in node
which is also its downside in big data
scenarios here just a quick example we
with this dolphin social network we can
read this this from a text file then
apply a measure like eigenvector
centrality to the network which is
similar to PageRank and then draw the
network where the size of the nodes is
proportional to the importance of the
node in terms of the centrality index
as I said the flexibility of network X
is also its downside in terms of
performance if you really need to do
graph data analysis at scale we you need
to apply the same trick that numpy
applies to gain efficiency we need to
put the algorithms and data structures
down into compile code and call them via
a Python API and the other certain
options here for example the eye graph
library the graph tool library and the
network kit library which is one that I
started during my PhD that's my own
small contribution to this ecosystem of
tools okay now to briefly talk about
what I would call meta tools they're not
necessarily data analysis tools but
they're so useful throughout this entire
process that I didn't want to exclude
them you probably most of you probably
know them and work with them it's for
example the ipython interactive Python
shell which is very powerful it also
gives you a collection of tools for
parallel computing and since I cannot
give an introduction to I - I just
picked one cool example of a ipython
extension that's very useful to me right
now because I have a colleague that
likes the language with the eccentric
syntax called R and if there's an I -
extension that's not called R PI 2 dot
ipython and formally known as our magic
and it turns out if you load this
extension into the ipython shell you can
very easily convert between pandas
dataframes
and our data frames here we for example
load again the iris data set as a
panda's data frame and with just this
annotation of the next cell we converted
transparently in the background to an R
data frame and now can apply our code in
this cell
the other other way around works of
course - we could read the fowl with our
and convert it to a panda's data frame
so this extension helps allows you to
seamlessly mix R and Python in one
project and of course what's extremely
useful is the Jupiter notebook gives you
interactive notebooks compiling code
documentation and graphics this is
actually the incarnation of the famous
computer scientist on newts literate
programming paradigm about which he
wrote a book in 1992 and I always
thought okay cool idea but why is nobody
using it it's really coming to fruition
here this is exactly what movement
literate programming programs that can
be read like a book insolently I did all
of the slides for the talks with Jupiter
it also gives you conversion tools to
export a notebooks to PDF or HTML slides
like here and since I can't go through
all the cool features of Jupiter I just
picked two cool things to plug at this
point something that was recommended to
me recently is the NV dime package this
is a package that gives you
content-aware
tipping on jupiter notebooks so usual
dipping like line-based
dips don't work so well with the jupiter
notebook file format envy dime fixes
this so he can finally compare notebooks
and of course integrate this into your
git workflow and if your organs
organization works collaboratively with
jupiter notebooks then a great addition
to your toolset is Jupiter hub which
gives you a multi-user server for
Jupiter notebooks
for example at my Institute we quite
successfully use this to share
large a lot at the computing power of a
large workstation collectively among the
different researchers okay that's the
end of our very quick guided tour I
thank you very much for your attention I
think we have some time for questions
left five minutes okay also if you want
to continue this conversation feel free
to get in touch through any of these
channels thank you very much
[Applause]
so we told us about the frameworks that
you like are there any frameworks or
tools in Python that you don't like and
you don't want to recommend it to anyone
oh there's this risky question now I
can't diss any I only work with the
tools that I like or I present the tools
that I would like to work with more and
so not this is not about criticizing any
package they're going to be on our
website certainly which is here you can
take a note thank you thank you
[Applause]